Canada's wildfires in Quebec Ontario and
Nova Scotia are leading to air quality
alerts in the U.S wind has carried smoke
from the wildfires Southward it's led to
New York City having some of the worst
air quality in the world this week
ranking in second place behind New Delhi
in India the smoke prompted New York's
Governor to encourage residents to
remain indoors as the haze will likely
linger for a few days air quality alerts
are also in effect for much of the
Northeast and Upper Midwest including
New England parts of Illinois Wisconsin
and Minnesota
I'm Not Afraid from my health I act like
it's probably only not probably
hopefully it's a temporary thing I mean
it's coming from Canada Unfortunately
they have all these wildfires going on
if anything I feel really
sad for them that they're going through
this situation so I mean
it's temporary unfortunately my children
had a really a great trip planned today
and it's further Upstate closer to
Canada and so they got canceled so they
have to stay inside so that sucked but
though I think we'll be fine what about
the hands well I'm a little worried
about it
um I thought yesterday it was going to
be a storm I thought it was a storm
coming in and then we started seeing the
air quality indexes so today was it we
had a big debate before the kids went to
school about should we be wearing masks
today oh there's all their activities
are indoors today
um so on the one hand I'm glad it should
be temporary but a little worried about
where they're breathing up today I feel
very bad I feel very bad sometimes like
I'm brief
it make briefing difficult
yeah I even I even scheduled for a road
test for driving for my driving license
today and it was canceled yeah I feel
very sad first of all I'll give a brief
public health update on what is an
emergency
situation emergency
crisis I would call this what we're
experiencing right now with the
substandard air quality in crisis it is
also a dangerous situation we've been
monitoring this for well over a week
since the fire started in Eastern Canada
and I would say over the last 48 hours
it's gotten significantly worse the haze
and the smoke from the fires you could
feel it even sitting indoors here uh
it's clogging much of our air in fact
it's almost impossible to see the sunset
or see the sky New York City and
Syracuse were among the worst places on
the entire planet yesterday and normally
our air quality index is around 50. in
New York state over the last 24 hours
and we just got these numbers in the
index hit my numbers this morning were
200 we have updated information is now
400. the index hit 400 in parts of our
state that's an 800 percent increase and
the bottom line is this if you can stay
indoors stay indoors this is detrimental
to People's Health